andrea
is with us in denver hi andrea how are
you
hi dave how are you and ken good how can
we help
um well first off please don't yell at
me
my husband and i um are
we got ourselves into a really
big mess and we're paying for it in a
really big way and the
worst part about it is that we knew
better we were maybe step four five
um for five and six um
and we decided that we wanted to buy
a house on some property that needed a
lot of fixing
up so we
bought it and we had about thirty five
thousand dollars in saving to
work on the house while we were waiting
for our old property to sell so that was
mistake number
one um got into it our house
defied all the odds i feel like in the
in the area that we're in
really good neighborhood really good
house we had some really weird things
happen
and a day before we were supposed to
close on this house
the deal fell through um so now
colorado got really really cold we
couldn't live there the way that it was
so we moved back into
our old house and we're just at a
crossroads because now we have
two mortgages um
the house that we were fixing up we we
got it down to the studs and ran out of
money
because i didn't want to spend our
emergency fund and then
we had a ton of emergencies that drain
that down to about three thousand
dollars and that's where we're sitting
at right now
so we have a ton of
friends and family that are speaking
into our lives about what we should do
but we feel like we've lost our center
and we would just wonder
what would do with ramsay do in our
situation
well you've had a hard year
yeah it's it's been really rough i'm
sorry but you know we put ourselves in
our
in that situation and again i felt like
we knew better no consolation it still
sucks
um okay
so your current residence is worth that
you're living in
is worth what uh
three the offer that we had was 3.45 we
put it on the market for about
350. and what do you owe on it
177. okay
all right um and the
money pit has how much oat on it
um we bought it for 350 we owed 280 on
it
okay and how much is the budget to
finish the repairs
um we believe that it would probably
about be
50 or 60. okay
um and um go ahead and the issues what
well the issue with that is we would
have enough to do that with the sale of
this house but we also
borrowed from his grandmother to do the
down payment on the farm which is 70.
okay so after after we pay her
and we sell this house if we were to
continue to go
that route we would have enough to
finish the house
okay and what is that house worth after
you spend
fifty thousand dollars on it
um we my real estate agent
and we've had a few other people
contractors and that
speak into it and the location is
amazing it's on 13 acres
what is that house worth when you spend
50 000 on it
we think it would be worth between 450
and 500.
okay so you get to do what you want to
do which is what you've done so far
you asked what i would do i would sell
your home
i would move into a rental i would
complete the renovation
and then i would sell that piece of crap
and then i would pay your grandmother
back
and go buy you another house
okay this house is not a dream
the second one it's a nightmare
parts of why you sold yourself on it and
led yourself down this
path where you got the crap beat out of
you is
are still in your brain it's a great
location i don't care if it's a great
location the house sucks
the whole story sucks and as long as you
live
in that house 20 years from now all
you're going to remember
is this horrible story you're never
going to enjoy that house
fix it and sell it with the money you
get from your house while you're renting
and then go buy something else
and get grandma paid off and then you
get to have a never again moment
and you know what the never again moment
is don't you
do you never again am i doing stupid
crap like this right
yes that's what i had when i went
bankrupt i had a never again moment
never again am i borrowing up to my
eyeballs
because i was doing what you're what you
did but but i did it with zeros on the
end because i was stupid
and i had a phd in the umb so you're
just a little bit
you're just tiny dumb compared to how
dumb i was but you got to learn your
lesson
and you got to cut the emotional garbage
loose from this thing
because there's no way i'm living in
that house not after it's destroyed your
family
i mean this thing has owned you
emotionally for 24 12 months however
long ever since you owned it
it's owned you the flip side to this
andre if you hear what dave's saying is
there is a way out of this
yeah and you feel as though the way
you're reacting
i understand you're discouraged but dave
just gave you a very clear
way to get out of this and it'll work
and i agree with you dave
but here's what they've got to focus on
a new desired future it's no longer that
place
it's wait a second there's other great
spots
out in their area in denver colorado are
you kidding me we also figured out
i'm not already she also says figured
out i'm not a rehabber that's right
that's why i don't need to do research
and they were already in four five and
six you need to buy
a house that you move into that's right
and
not even a closet needs painting no more
renovations for you they can erase this
and start on a new canvas it's going to
hurt yeah that's right they're actually
probably going to end up
netting a profit when all the smoke
clears
the way i saw the numbers yes they come
out of this real relatively
financially unscathed you know other
than just the emotional
embarrassed and ashamed that's right but
that's uh
you know and some scars from that
there's more let me just beg you
having done what i do for 30 years and
having owned real estate i've owned
thousands of pieces of real estate over
2 000 pieces in my life
do not fix this house and move in it you
will
hate it it will never
feel right because of what it has done
to you
and always be this reminder of the dumb
thing that i did
every time you walk through that hallway
every time you you know
just don't do it you say please you do
whatever you want to do
but i mean i i try to get rid of things
that remind me of my stupidity and the
other i want things around that remind
me of the time i was smart
it's true and there's plenty of both
that's right and they
they don't have to you know live this
the rest of their life they can go all
right we did this
thankfully we got out of it and now
let's go find another thing let's
rebuild
and let's find another great vision and
let's go after that and and
that's the key they've got to sever the
emotional tie to this deal yeah and
here's the thing
it's a house there's houses everywhere
that's right there is no unicorn
property
there's just not i mean there's not a
property that says there's never been
one they could never be
i mean there's about 10 properties in
every city that might qualify for that
other than that
most of it you can probably replicate i
mean it's just a house on every corner
you can figure this out so i would cut
all of it loose
start fresh call it an adventure call it
a day
the good news is you're not losing a
half million dollars
and having to start over on your wealth
building you're actually probably going
to come out with a net net net profit
after grandma
after the renovations after the recoup
of the 35 you spent out of your savings
and the sale of both properties all of
it back in a pile i think if i
if i heard the numbers right you're
going to come out okay so it's just an
emotional process and
no this hour kind of had a theme of like
forgive yourself
that she was worried she worried i was
going to yell at her you know who's
yelling at her her
i'm not in yet yeah you know you you've
been yelling at yourself
a lot louder than i have but don't
don't try to halfway go through this you
almost it'll be a mistake
clean slate rip the band-aid off get a
fresh start